ADAM LEONARD: All right,
welcome everyone.
My name is Adam Leonard.
I'm with Google's People
Development department and I'm
happy to introduce and to
welcome Jake Breeden today to
introduce and to talk
about his new book,
"Tipping Sacred Cows--
Kick the Bad Work Habits that
Masquerade as Virtues."
So Jake teaches as part of the
faculty, global faculty, for
Duke Corporate Education, which
is one of the world's
top-ranked providers of custom
corporate education.
And it's taken him around the
world, over 27 countries,
consulting with numerous
corporations, including Google.
So he did work coaching and
challenging leaders as part of
Google's Business Academy.
And so I'm particularly
interested in Jake's talk
today because one of things he's
going to do in tipping
these sacred cows is, challenge
many of the things
that we hold to be important
around here-- collaboration,
creativity.
And we're also, in my experience
so far, we're good
at holding ambiguity.
And so I think I'm welcoming
Jake's challenge to see, what
are the other side of some
of these things that
we hold to be sacred?
So welcome, Jake.
JAKE BREEDEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
When you're young, you probably
preferred simple
flavors, simple textures.
You know, lemonade, rice.
Simple tastes, simple flavors
when you were young, perhaps.
Candy, cola.
And as you've gotten a little
bit older, you've begun to
crave more complex flavors.
The seemingly paradoxical
flavors of like a briny caviar
that's also savory, or a dark
chocolate that's bittersweet,
or a wine for some of you, like
an earthy Bordeaux wine.
More complex flavors.
In the same way that our mouths
crave more complex
tastes as we age, our minds
crave more complex ideas.
Young minds crave
simple ideas.
They crave ideas, but putting
things into buckets and
understanding where the
pieces fit, what piece
fits in what bucket.
And as our minds mature, we
begin to crave more ideas in
the same way that are mouths
crave more complex tastes.
And a complex idea that leaders,
especially crave, and
especially successful leaders
crave, are paradoxical ideas.
There's a pretty striking piece
of research that looked
at folks along a broad set of
companies, a broad set of
industries, a broad set of
countries, and said, what
separates people who stay in
the middle management level
from folks to move
up to the top?
That was the research question
that they asked.
And there are many answers, but
somewhat surprisingly, the
thing that stood out was the
preference for paradox.
That the most successful leaders
have brains that don't
just deal well with paradoxical
ideas, but crave
them in the same way that
our palates might
crave a complex taste.
I want to share with you today
three paradoxes, and I'll
present three paradoxes for
your consideration.
These are the three--
first, that to have more
excellence, you must have less
excellence.
And in particular, to have more
excellence in the things
that matter most, you must have
less excellence where it
doesn't matter as much.
Being purposeful about the way
you think about standards.
Second, that to have more
collaboration, you must have
less collaboration.
And what I mean is, to have more
collaboration where it
counts, where it leads to the
things that you need more of,
the kind of innovation that you
need more of, for example,
the business results that you
need more of, you actually
need less collaboration in other
areas, in other places.
And we'll talk about the
problem of too much
collaboration.
And we'll talk in particular
about the way that virtue like
collaboration tends
to act as a mask.
It prevents us from seeing
what's really going on, which
we're excusing away
bad behavior.
We say, hey I'm collaborating,
I'm playing well with others,
I'm doing what at what
I should be doing.
When actually, it's masking
some bad behavior.
In this particular case
of collaboration, not
collaborating with the kinds
of folks who could be more
productive for you.
And the third paradox we'll
look at is that to be more
creative, you must
be less creative.
And in particular, we'll talk
about the way that needless
creativity, narcissistic
creativity, saps energy from
the pragmatic creativity that
you actually need to get
things done.
So there's this interplay
between the good excellence
and the bad excellence, the good
collaboration and the bad
collaboration, and the good
creativity and the bad
creativity.
That's how we'll spend about
the next 25 minutes, and in
each of them I'll do a bit of
setup and I'll get you talking
with somebody next to you to
see if you can uncover some
times where you've fallen into
the trap of the bad.
And then I'll have a bit of Q&A
and I'll leave you with
one last thought, and sign a
few books, and all of this
will be done by, let's say,
five minutes to two.
Ready to go?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
JAKE BREEDEN: All right, let's
start with excellence.
So I'm going to give you a
piece of data and then
together, let's make some
meaning from the data.
And then let's see if we can
go from the meaning to a
recommendation.
So here's the data.
There's a woman named Emerald
Archer who did her Ph.D. at UC
Santa Barbara in political
psychology.
She studied female Marines at
Camp Pendleton, a Marine base
outside of San Diego.
And she was interested in one
question, which is, why do
female Marines under perform
their male companions, their
male colleagues, their male
peers, on the rifle range?
Right?
So she studies performance of
Marines on the rifle range
looking at performance
by gender to try
to answer this question.
What is it?
And she did the following
test.
Her hypothesis was that when the
female Marines were primed
to think of the test as a test
of gender, they would perform
worse than if they didn't
think of it as a test of
gender, that if gender
didn't matter.
And so what she would do is, she
would, in one condition,
she would prime the female
Marines before they would go
to the rifle range and
shoot at, by the
way, 500 meters, right?
So this is incredibly long
distance when they're shooting
on the rifle range at
Camp Pendleton.
And in one condition, she would
prime the women, the
Marines, to say, there's a lot
of research that says women,
here's the data, women tend to
under perform, at sort of 85%,
shoot at about 85% the success
rate of their male colleagues.
This is a test of that.
Let's see how we do.
And then the other group, she
had only women, but she didn't
tell them that this was a
test of a gender at all.
She just, it was made to seem
as if it's random, that it
just happened to be four women
there shooting at a range,
there are no men around
and there was no
priming around gender.
And in fact, when there was no
priming and when there was
only women there, they shot at
exactly the same level as men.
Much higher than they had
been shooting before.
So she presents her research,
and it's quite clear that when
primed to think of the test
as a test of gender, they
underperformed the other
scenario, when they weren't
primed to think of it
as a test of gender.
So that's the data.
What do you think is
going on there?
What's your interpretation
of that?
AUDIENCE: So when you're
[INAUDIBLE]
that a certain condition is met,
like you're more likely
to extreme that position because
maybe you're not
[INAUDIBLE].
JAKE BREEDEN: Self-fulfilling
prophecy, essentially.
So OK, any other ideas?
Self-fulfilling prophecy, one.
What else?
Same data, any other ways
to interpret the data?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: You could be worried
that you're getting measured
on other variables, and so their
focus, like, the idea
that they're focusing a little
bit less on like, actual
shoot, like, shooting the rifle
because they're focusing
on excellence in other
areas, I presume?
JAKE BREEDEN: Oh,
I see, I see.
So this would be the
psychological concept there is
crowding out.
So they're focused on these
other areas, these other
variables, that actually don't
help the performance in the
tested condition, right?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
JAKE BREEDEN: So I'll share with
you Emerald's point of
view, what she says, and this
is one of these things where
nobody knows what the
real answer is.
We know what the data is.
When you go to interpretation,
this is a matter of theory and
interpretation.
But I'll tell you hers.
So Emerald, again,
Emerald Archer
studying at UC Santa Barbara.
I interviewed her
about this test.
It turns out, she grew up
outside of Camp Pendleton as a
little girl.
Her father was a contractor
and he worked building the
barracks on the Marine base.
And he would often have Marines
over for picnics.
And so she said, typically on a
Saturday or Sunday we might
have several Marines grilling
out, having a picnic.
And she said at a young age, she
says, this is her talking,
I noticed the following
thing--
that the women would sort
of take care of
things at this picnic.
They would pick up after the
guys, they would get the beers
or clean up.
And she said as a young woman,
as a young girl, this seemed
ridiculous to me.
And she said, I even noticed
that when the women outranked
the guys, that gender ended up
being a greater predictor of
the sort of social subservience
than rank.
So you would literally have
higher ranking Marines sort of
taking care of things.
So she became, at a young age,
you can picture this young
woman, she's focused on that, so
she dedicates her career to
trying to understand this, and
it becomes the focus of or a
Ph.D. dissertation.
Here's Emerald's, Emerald's
thought is that it's
essentially along the lines of
the crowding out, that the
cognitive load, the
cognitive load of
worrying about this category.
In this case, women, the
cognitive load of worrying
about this category, robs the
Marines of the cognitive
attention they need to give
to this act of shooting.
And this falls more broadly
under an area called
stereotype threat, and it's been
shown, for example, with
student athletes.
You go to universities and you
get a set of student athletes
and you prime them to think
of themselves primarily as
student athletes and says it's
shown that student athletes
tend to under perform their
colleagues who aren't student
athletes on standardized
tests.
Now take a standardized test.
And sure enough, the sort of the
notion of, I want to prove
it, ends up being paramount.
And by the way, the anecdotes
supported the notion when she
would interview the female
Marines who were engaged in
these tests in which they'd been
primed, they would say
things like, I was going
to make sure.
I was going to make sure that
this false stereotype, that we
can't shoot as well as
a man, was disproven.
And this was one woman in the
study, she went on to say, but
unfortunately, I did
the opposite.
Unfortunately, I did
And unfortunately, I did the
opposite, is kind of the theme
to the study, to the book.
Unfortunately, I did
the opposite.
It's the undead unintended
consequence.
So we're still in excellence,
this first paradox, and the
punch line is, to get to an
excellent destination,
sometimes you have to take a
meandering path and lower the
stakes, lower the standards.
So think about this now, think
about yourself, think about
perfectionism.
Think about times when
you're working
hard to prove something.
This is when it's especially
dangerous, when you need to
prove a point to yourself
or to someone else.
Maybe it's part of a class
that you belong that's is
perceived to not to
be as strong.
It's shown, we have this insight
that the cognitive
load, it simply becomes
overbearing, your need to
prove that you can do
this thing well.
And unfortunately, the opposite,
but you end up
proving the opposite true,
unfortunately.
Before I get you to talk to a
neighbor on, about how, what
are you trying to prove, and to
whom, and how does it get
in your way of performance, I
want to give you a glimmer of
hope, of light, an example,
a success story.
A success story of this, what I
would propose, is a healthy
use of excellence, a healthy
use of high standards.
And it's in your neighborhood,
in your neck of
the words with Pixar.
So raise your hand if you saw
the movie, "Aladdin." Did
anybody see the movie,
"Aladdin?" Not a Pixar film.
Look around.
Most of you saw "Aladdin." raise
your hand if you saw,
not the first sequel to
"Aladdin", but the second
sequel to "Aladdin." It was
called "Aladdin King of
Thieves." Raise your hand if
you saw "Aladdin King of
Thieves." OK one person, two
people saw "Aladdin King of
Thieves."
All right, now the next piece of
data here, raise your hand
if you saw the movie,
"Toy Story."
OK, pretty much everybody.
Now, but here's the, this is the
money question, raise your
hand if you saw "Toy Story 3."
OK, also, like about 60% of
the people.
So what I would want to shine
a spotlight is, if we were
doing bar charts here, the drop
off between "Aladdin" and
"Aladdin King of Thieves"
was from here to there.
The drop off between "Toy Story"
and "Toy Story 3" was
here to there a little bit.
Actually, "Toy Story 3" sold
more, did more at the box
office than "Toy Story." "Toy
Story 3" is the most
successful Pixar film to date
commercially and arguably,
critically, because it was
nominated for Best Picture.
Not just Best Animated,
but Best Picture.
So here's the point.
Pixar has an attitude that says,
even our sequels, we
will reject the old Disney
approach of,
let's sweat the asset.
Meaning, we invested a lot in
"Lion King", we invested a lot
in "Aladdin", now let's invest
much, much less.
We'll go direct to video and
what we're just going to get
returns off of the second
sequel, the third sequel We'll
invest a little bit, but
we'll make a little bit
more and it's OK.
Pixar rejects that.
Pixar says, everything we do
is going to be excellent.
Every single thing we do is
going to be excellent.
Doesn't sound like the notion
of being at a rifle range,
saying, it must be excellent.
Here's the difference--
the habit they have every
single day is, you share
incomplete work.
Imagine you're an animator.
You're 23 years old, you get
your dream job working at
Pixar as an animator and it's
4 o'clock on your first day
and you gather around and,
OK, let's share what you
worked on so far.
And you're going to be asked
to share with somebody who
just won the Oscar for Best
Animated Feature last year.
It could be intimidating.
And the first day, it
is intimidating.
But here's what the leaders
do, they build a habit of
sharing incomplete work.
So it takes the sting of shame
out of in-completion.
It takes the sting of shame
out of rough progress.
They get more rough drafts,
rougher rough drafts, more
progress, more willingness to
just put your stuff out there,
put yourself out there.
They lower the stakes instead
of raising the stakes and
saying, this must be good.
They lower the stakes and they
say, let's just get more and
more drafts, more reps, more
versions out of this thing.
Let's create a culture
where it's a habit,
it's not a big deal.
You just share your stuff.
That's just what we do.
And as a result, they have a
better shot, no guarantee,
there's no guarantees in
anything artistic like trying
to make a successful film.
No guarantees the same process
that they used in "Toy Story
3", they used in "Brave"
to less success.
It still made money, but not at
the level of "Toy Story 3",
but what it does is, it
increases the chances that
you'll achieve excellence
in the end.
So here's what I want
you to do now.
I'm going to ask you, I'm going
to invite you, to talk
to one person in
the room here.
So find a group, so group two,
maybe groups of three, and
just have this chat.
When do we ever here, fall into
the trap of unhealthy
excellence, of high standards
that don't help?
Is my question clear?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK, so just for
three, four minutes, have a
chat with somebody near you.
I'm curious if anyone would be
willing to just share the
example they talked about?
Not required at all, but
just the opportunity.
Anyone willing to share?
AUDIENCE: It's not my experience
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm a researcher.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK.
AUDIENCE: But there was, at the
beginning, when I started
[INAUDIBLE].
JAKE BREEDEN: Not here,
but some other place?
AUDIENCE: Not here.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
anxiety of having the research
report perfect.
All the data, all the
recommendations, all the new
designs, all the proposals.
Everything [INAUDIBLE] right.
right And then, you know, when
I decided to drop that and
say, no, what I care about, the
product, I care out the
PMs, I care about [INAUDIBLE]
and I don't care about having an
amazing report [INAUDIBLE].
Academic research, you know.
JAKE BREEDEN: So helping the
PMs move things forward?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAKE BREEDEN: That's
what mattered?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAKE BREEDEN: The perfection of
the report didn't matter.
The report was there to help
the PMs move things forward
along the development process.
So this is a great example of a
punchline, before I move on,
here here's the punchline, you
may need to do less than
excellent work in order to
do an excellent job.
I want everybody in this room
to think about doing an
excellent job, and everyone
to think about doing
an excellent job.
And in order to do an excellent
job, in, for
example, moving things along
with the PMs, to do an
excellent job at that, you may
need to permit yourself to do
a little bit less than excellent
work, and that can
be really, really hard.
What I'm asking you to do
though, is to have the sort of
intellectual sophistication and
the maturity to decouple
the work from the job.
And importantly, and here's the
real psychological punch,
to decouple the work
from yourself.
To say, this is my
work, not me.
I'm an excellent human being,
and as an excellent human
being, it may be that I
need to produce less
than excellent work.
So we all are constantly on
that journey of decoupling
ourselves from our work.
The second paradox--
in order to have more
collaboration, you need to
have less collaboration.
And in particular, in order to
have the kind of collaboration
that helps, you need to
collaborate less.
Some of the research that I did
for this book, and here's
is an anecdote, talked to
somebody who worked at a big
company who is a senior
director.
Senior director at a big
company and he said, I
surveyed everybody on my team
and I got the average of the
following variable--
number of hours per week spent
in standing meetings,
regularly recurring meetings,
meetings that you know, on
Sunday night, you know your
week has these meetings in
them already.
And the number for people
on his team was 22.
I'm not sure what it would be
for you, if that would be
higher or low for you,
for 22 hours.
Here's a here's the
problem, though.
These 22 hours of standing
meeting, they were mostly, I
mean, by definition, by being
the standing, regularly
recurring, were with people
who they knew.
With friends, you might say.
People in the inner circle.
That's collaboration.
We want to celebrate
collaboration.
Collaboration is a virtue.
Work more with others.
Play well with others.
Except when your collaboration
muscle is exerted in spending
more time with the people you
work with and who think
similarly to you, it ends up
giving less space and time for
the more helpful collaboration
across boundaries, across
borders, to people who think
differently than you.
And it turns out that the
animating force behind this,
the driving force behind this,
is that it just feels good to
be around people who
think like us.
It just, it's so soothing.
It's like a nice, warm, cuddly
blanket to be surrounded by
like minded people.
It's just this safe, snuggly
environment to say, yes, I
don't even have to try.
I can just say, this
is what I think.
Oh, you think that, too?
Oh, yes, this feels so good.
We all think the same thing.
You're not a bad person.
You are a person if you
behave in that way.
You are a human being.
We are social.
We are a social species and we
tend to cluster and clump in
these like groups.
So here's the big point.
What's preventing you from
collaborating is
collaboration.
It's not individual.
It's often presented as, stop
being such a Lone Ranger.
You're not in the
Lone Star state,
don't be the Lone Ranger.
Don't be just an individual,
rugged cowboy.
You need to spend more time
working with others.
Actually, that's not
the dynamic.
If you look at the research,
what's soaking up the time
that could be spent in
collaborating with other
folks, what's soaking up the
time is collaborating with
people like you.
And so there's a simple
punchline, which is, in your
collaboration, you
should do less
spinning and more hopping.
And spinning is just more
meetings with the people who
you work with, who
are on your team.
And more hopping across
other teams.
A.G. Lafley, very successful CEO
of Procter & Gamble, one
of the things he did when it got
to the top is he said, we
are constantly internally
looking at process, talking
about process, designing
process, to look the process,
and evaluating things in a very
process-friendly way.
And as we're doing that, we're
looking at each other and our
backside is facing
the customer.
When our backside is facing
the customer, when all our
stuff is internal, intrinsic,
we're not getting enough real
life hard data from
the real world.
There's a phenomenon, if you
look across species, called
the bait ball.
So fish school together when
faced with a predator.
Gazelles form a herd when
We human beings can also cluster
together and clump
together because
it feels safe.
Too often, we collaborate to
hide, not to accomplish.
So my suggestion is that we sort
of divert some of that
energy from collaborating with
like minded people to
collaborating across.
With that, I'm reading
your body language.
Did you did you disagree with
something that I said?
AUDIENCE: Me?
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No.
JAKE BREEDEN: No?
OK all right, maybe you--
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking about it.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK.
Because I love disagreement.
I mean, that's one of the things
I'm a big advocate, one
of the things, the hero of the
book is challenge and push
back, and so some--
let me make that explicit.
We've been together now 25
minutes, we're good friends.
So push back a challenge
at any point.
SAM: Are you say you
need to do both?
JAKE BREEDEN: There we
go, there's Sam.
So Sam says, are you saying
you need to do both?
SAM: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE] facing
the customer as far as facing
internally.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah, what I'm
saying, to be clear, is do
less of the thing where you're
collaborating more with people
like you and more of the thing
where you're collaborating
with people less like you.
And the less like you, use your
own judgment as to what
that means in your particular
context.
I am not a zealot.
One point of "Tipping Sacred
Cows" is anti-zealotry, right?
So I'm not a zealot saying you
can go all the way to one.
I am saying, right now, the
balance is a little bit out of
kilter, is my suggestion.
So do you think, does that
happen here, the notion of
collaborating within your
group, perhaps to the
detriment of collaborating
across groups?
Spinning instead of hopping?
Some people are nodding
their heads, yes.
What are some successful
ways to avoid that?
Has any of you seen that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: On my team we've
done collaborative OKRs.
So you have to have an OKR
that's based on someone else's
team and that person on that
team has to have the same one
as you so that you work
on it together.
That tries to keep
you outside.
You still work [INAUDIBLE]
media team to get the work done,
but it just gives you
kind of a goal to work for
somebody on a different team
with a different perspective on
a project or a topic or a
solution that kind of
just gets you out of
your comfort zone.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK.
I think that's good.
That's a good example.
It parallels the Pixar example
of a purposeful attempt.
That is one of the primary
things that I advocate, is a
little bit more purpose.
If you just go with the tide,
you will end up collaborating
with people like you
and in a way that's
perhaps more helpful.
Have purpose and intent
to say I they need to
reach across borders.
Were you going to
say something?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE].
Make standing meetings
literally standing.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Because that naturally
limits the amount of
time you spend doing it.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yes, put the
physiology on your side.
And often, when you're sitting
down, the physiology
is not on your side.
So there may be like, a little
part of your brain, the
unhealthy part of your brain,
that says, come up with excuse
to stay in this comfy
chair longer.
And that part of your brain,
well I have another point I'd
like to suggest.
That's not healthy,
helpful behavior.
One last thing about
collaboration.
Talk to me about
brainstorming.
I'm interested, is brainstorming
good?
AUDIENCE: To a point.
JAKE BREEDEN: Brainstorming
is good to a point?
Is brainstorming bad?
Raise your hand if you think
brainstorming is a bad idea,
proven to be unhelpful.
Looks like one person.
Tell me more about your
point of view.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and like you said, a lot of
findings that brainstorming,
you tend to revisit the same
points and clump your
[INAUDIBLE]
because everyone
is saying, yes.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah.
So let me be clear about
my point of view.
And it is based on some of the
findings that you talk about.
There's a woman at Berkeley
who's done
a lot of this research.
Brainstorming is bad.
It destroys value, it
doesn't add value.
Now, brainstorming is good
at the following thing.
It's good at, it's fun.
It's good at, as a kind
of team builder.
It's cheaper than going go
kart racing and can make
people feel good, like, yea,
let's just come up with a
bunch of ideas together.
And it feels good.
So it's good for that, but
it's not good for work in
terms of, you don't produce
better ideas by brainstorming.
And in particular, so this is a
surprise to some of you, the
research is so clear, yet the
myth still persists that
brainstorming adds value.
I mean, it's really, it's 50
years old, the research that
shows that brainstorming
is bad.
So let me be clear, in a
research-based way, what do I
mean by brainstorming?
I mean getting a bunch of people
in a room and saying,
what do you think we do
about this problem?
What's your idea?
What's your suggestion?
It turns out that that's a less
utility in that approach
than having individual people
separately, on their own,
quietly write down and come
up with a list of ideas.
You end up with fewer ideas
and lower quality of ideas
when you get people together.
And let's just get our heads
together on this one because
there's this myth that just,
more is better than less, we
need more people in there and
let's brainstorm ideas.
And just, the research
doesn't bear it out.
The woman's name at Berkeley,
her last name is Nemeth, so
some of you are interested
this, it's N-E-M-E-T-H.
N-E-M-E-T-H. Charlan,
C-H-A-R-L-A-N
is the first name.
So if you were to just search
for Nemeth you could see that.
There's another particular thing
within brainstorming
that is unhelpful, and it's a
myth, and that's the notion
that you shouldn't criticize
other ideas.
You know, this is a magic room,
this is a brainstorm,
we're just going to put
ideas on the table.
Again, that's really good for
maximizing likeability, but
it's not good for maximizing
productivity,
for getting the ideas.
And I would say to leaders, a
lot of the work that I do is
with leaders, it's a leader's
job to make it safe for people
to criticize each
other's ideas.
If you have a situation where
we must just say nice things
about each other's ideas, you
have an absence of leadership.
Because that's an absence of the
kind of rigor that's going
to lead to good work and good
thinking if you're not able to
actually have an environment
where people can criticize
each other's ideas.
So individually, be individually
strong,
collaborate reluctantly,
and collaborate
towards some purpose.
Bring in other people's ideas
and then beat the heck out of
each other's ideas.
And this only works, though,
in an environment where you
trust each other and you're
OK criticizing
each other's ideas.
So that's the second.
I'll go with the third and final
before Q&A, then I'll do
one last thing after Q&A,
then book signing.
So the third is creativity.
So to get more creativity,
you need less creativity.
And in particular, to get the
kind of creativity that is
pragmatic and useful, you need
less of the kind of creativity
that is, and I'm going to
be very specific here,
narcissistic.
Creativity is an excuse, often,
to hide narcissism.
So we as individuals want
to put our finger
prints on the world.
And this drive is often
counterproductive.
The drive to put our finger
prints on the world is
counterproductive.
We want to create something new
because it feels good and
we're driven to make our
mark and to leave
our mark on the world.
And in some cases, the
particular part of the world
doesn't need that mark.
Now I'm not suggesting that
people not pursue their
passion when it comes to art, or
make your mark on the world
in that way.
What I'm saying is, again, have
the intellectual rigor,
the sophistication, the
maturity, to decouple that
from what is needed in this
particular work project and
say, actually in this case, what
we need is the same thing
we've always done.
Even though that doesn't feel
as gratifying to my ego,
that's what the work needs, is
for us to simply repeat what
we've done before.
Innovate when you need to,
not when you want to.
So here's a quick example of
some narcissistic creativity,
and it was done in Silicon
Valley in this neck of the
words in 1996 by me.
So here's my narcissistic
creativity as a young kid.
I was, would be 24
in 1996, and I'm
working for this company.
In 1996 they had the, Vivo
had the first compression
algorithms to digitize video.
It was based on the work of
Doctor Stefan Eriksson did at
the Royal Institute
of Technology
in Stockholm, Sweden.
So Dr. Stefan Eriksson had many
of the first patents in
the compression of video
and into digital code.
And he started out in the early
'90s by trying to turn
his research into video
conferencing.
That wasn't going
along so well.
In the meantime, he's seeing
companies like Netscape
getting funded at these huge
valuations and he's saying,
look, at I've got this
great product.
I want to become
a web company.
So I was part of the team to
help him market that and
publicize that and say,
Vivo is a web company.
And what we did in spring of
1996, we want to something
called Spring Internet World.
Anybody who was around back in
the early sort of, right as
the bubble's starting to
get inflated, in '96.
Spring Internet World, we said,
we're going to take it
to Spring Internet World and
tell the world about your
ability to put video over the
web, which this is in the days
of 28.8 modem, so it's very
primitive technology.
But he could do it, just barely,
could get video over
28.8 bandwidth, narrow
band, into the home.
So, and he didn't have much at
all, but he was running out of
money, so we go to Spring
Internet World and when we see
this logo, I don't know about
you, a but when I saw this
logo in particular, I didn't
just see Vivo.
I, being a very creative
boy, I saw Vivo man.
So we are going, because, I
mean, I thought like, the O is
like a mouth and the Vs are like
eyes and the I is kind of
a nose, like a little bit,
do you see his little
anthropomorphic?
Look, I'm telling you, this
is a bad idea, right?
The whole point is,
it's a bad idea.
But man, I wanted to help.
So I sold Dr. Stefan Eriksson
on, we need, at Spring
Internet World, we don't need
to just have a booth.
We need to have Vivo Man.
And we need to have Vivo Man
like, walking around the trade
show getting people to go to the
booth-- this is the world
a little bit in 1996--
and saying, look at
the first ever
video compression algorithm.
So this is Vivo Man.
And he's a very nice Swedish
scientist and he said, OK,
fine, do it.
So I'm in Boston and
he's in Cambridge.
I'm in Boston and we designed
this thing, we staff an actor
out here, somebody from San
Jose State, I think, who's
going to be the actor who's
going to walk around.
And we had this costume made
with purple Spandex, costume
to fit the purple logo, and
we booked the actor.
When we got out here, it turns
out the actor, you know, we
built the suit for someone very
tall and broad shoulders,
like a superhero, right?
But the actor, there was some
miscommunication and the
implementation of the idea
didn't go so well, and indeed,
the actor was not shaped
in the way.
I don't have a picture of it,
but this is just from a quick
search if you want
to get a sense.
This is sort of the, that
was basically--
that gives you a sense of what
we were dealing with.
So this was the picture of Vivo
Man, this is actually
what happened, and then so we
get our Vivo Man in there, and
I'm red-faced with
embarrassment,
it's not going well.
As we get Vivo Man there, and
we're told, as we get him onto
the show floor, this very
serious woman stops me and she
says, do you have a character
appearance license?
Because there's a $10,000
character appearance fee.
And we did not, and I did
not know about that.
So I had to escort Vivo Man
out to the bus stop where
people were dropping off the
attendees, because that was
the best we could do.
So that was, as my 13-year-old
daughter would
say, that was a fail.
That did not work, having
Vivo Man there.
And it was ridiculous.
It was just one of these things
that was, it's an
exaggerated example, right?
It's an exaggerated example and
I'm making fun of myself.
I think we can all find
examples where we did
something, you sort of start
falling in love with the idea
and the idea takes inertia of
its own and it's the coolness
of the idea and versus
what is needed.
Let me tell you what worked
there, though.
What worked is the simplest,
easiest thing in the world.
We, at our little booth
space, we said we will
be Vivo Video News.
And we're going to copy CNN.
Instead of CNN, we're VVN.
And I called myself a senior
producer for VVN.
I contacted people before the
show and said, we want to
interview you, get your thoughts
on the internet and
this will be the first ever,
what we call, we hadn't heard
the word before, maybe it had
been used before, but we said,
this is going to be the
first-ever webcast.
And so we were using this word
webcast in 1996, he's got the
first compression algorithms.
We interviewed people for VVN
and they'd come to the booth.
And the whole goal of this was
to get an infusion of funding
so that the company could live
and potentially be acquired.
And there was a company called
Real Audio at the time that
later became Real Networks that
did, that weekend, an
infusion of capital and
then acquired Vivo.
And that's how Real entered
the video space is by
acquiring this, and it was Dr.
Stefan Eriksson's algorithms.
Here's the point.
Copying CNN was the
right thing to do.
It was a simple idea, like OK,
why don't we cover the event
using our technology?
Duh!
There's no, like, you don't
get an award for being so
super creative.
It's the most obvious
thing in the world.
Here's who was creative, by the
way, Dr. Stefan Eriksson,
who created the algorithms.
That was creative.
Like that was, the fact that we
were going to come up with
this nonsense to try to promote
it with some crazy
character was just silliness.
It was just a waste.
So that's an example of how easy
it is to fall into the
trap of narcissistic creativity
instead of
creativity that's driven by some
business outcome, which
is, let's be acquired.
We had, by the way, there's
only, I think, eight people
who came by our booth to be
interviewed, but all eight, it
was Microsoft was there, Real
was there, HP was there.
And then some of the old
line VCs, what were
big VCs back in '96.
But those were the right
eight people.
I mean, we were at a trade
show and Vivo Man, and we
think it's cool because he's
going to be seen by 20,000
people, it was those eight
people that mattered.
So the punchline about
creativity is, the theme of
the day, have the intellectual
sophistication, the
intellectual rigor, and the
maturity to say, creativity in
and of itself is not good.
But here's more to the point--
creativity is often a mask.
It's a mask that excuses
narcissism.
Creativity is a mask that
excuses narcissism.
You say, I'm not being
ridiculously narcissistic.
I'm being creative and I'm
told that creativity is a
value and a virtue.
Beware.
Be very careful about the
unintended consequences of
creativity.
As I said, I've got one more
thing that I'm going to close
on, but first.
I'd love to hear questions,
comments, push backs?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: How do you balance the
risk of creativity versus
[INAUDIBLE] peer syndrome with
the need to sort of be
disruptive?
Like, if everyone else in your
industry is approaching the
same problems with the same old
thing, h do you make sure
that you're not the one who's
left behind and someone else
finds that new thing?
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah.
So I'm a big fan of disruption
as a process.
And so if you read Clay
Christensen, who wrote "The
Innovator's Dilemma" and talked
about the innovator's
dilemma and disruptive
innovation, one of the things
he talks about is, that being
disruptive is a process.
And you can't guarantee that you
will disrupt an industry,
but you can increase the chances
that you will disrupt
an industry by following
a few steps.
And so I'm a big believer
in what he did '97 with
"Innovator's Dilemma" and in
2003 with "Innovator's
Solution." In "Innovator's
Solution" in particular, he
talks about, what is the job
to be done by the customer?
And how am I going to really
understand the job that's
going to be done?
And in some cases, that means
excellence can get in the way.
I need to be the good enough
solution on one dimension so
that I can outperform on
another dimension.
I think that kind of rigor is
more helpful than a sort of a
general permissiveness
about creativity.
So that's my answer, is I
would say, you should be
disruptive and you should zag
when other people are zigging.
And that doesn't
mean, therefore
let's just be creative.
Is that a?
AUDIENCE: No, that
makes sense.
JAKE BREEDEN: OK, cool.
That was a good question,
I liked the question.
Come on, give me some
more questions.
And it doesn't have
to be that good.
Let's lower the standards
on questions.
I mean, this is a problem
with excellence.
So the lead off question is this
really smart, informed
question and so now people are
like, well I'm not going to
ask anything.
Like, somebody ask
a question--
this is a challenge in the
spirit of how unhelpful high
standards in excellence
can be.
Somebody answer a question that
you might feel just a
tinge of shame even in asking.
Like, what you mean by that?
Or, wait, I don't understand.
Maybe I'm the only one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is more
of a comment.
I noticed that when I send a
document to collaborate with
others, if I intentionally make
it lower quality, I get a
lot more collaboration.
And when it's, you know, pretty
and has great, table of
contents and everything there,
I barely get anything.
So I intentionally always make
sure that whenever I seek
actual input, just have
placeholders where people can
fill it in.
And that works.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah, I love that
I love that approach,
that idea of, and you
can announce it.
You can say.
It's not like you need to be
manipulative in any way to
say, these are my quick,
rough thoughts.
Your feedback and input
is critical here.
Just more reps, more
revisions.
That's a great way to combine
the excellence and the
collaboration piece.
What else?
Yes, Sam?
SAM: Say your manager asking
for excellence.
The whole team member expects it
and it's based on what you
just told us just [INAUDIBLE]?
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How would you
deal with that?
JAKE BREEDEN: So what if the
manager's asking for
excellence?
You simply say, I read this book
by Jake Breeden and he --
no, of course not.
I think it's the point of the
differences between the job
and the work, so this woman who,
she had to leave early,
her point was, her job was to
help PMs move the development
cycle, move products through
the development cycle.
That's her job.
And I would hope that her boss
wants her to do an excellent
job of that.
And so if her boss is giving
her a hard time about the
research reports, like wait a
minute, you only have four
origin citations here, why
don't you, you know, this
other person had 14 original
citations on the research.
Are you sure you had
enough sources?
I would want some conversation,
say , help me
understand here.
Let me make sure we're on the
same page about what's the
job, what are we really
trying to achieve?
So that you're managing
up, and in fact,
you're leading up.
Because if you do it right,
you're going to help your boss
expand the thinking.
You have to do it in a way
that's not defensive.
And it could be that your boss
is way ahead of you.
It could be that your boss is
thinking, actually, the job to
be done is something different
than what you just said.
And so then you're having
a good conversation.
But I think this, to me, the
most helpful strategy is the
difference between the
word job and work.
Just to decouple job from work
and to say, we got to do an
excellent job.
Boss, I am on board with
excellence when it comes to
the job we're trying to do.
So big picture here,
what's the job?
Now, where are some incremental
steps, some
inputs, so to speak, where
actually, I want more lower
quality inputs than just a few
big high quality inputs.
I would have that kind
of conversation.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Question around
your comments that
brainstorming is bad.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: And I'm wondering, in
that research, does it, is
there any differentiation
between the psychology of
teams in regard to typology?
So if you have a team of
introverts, say a Myers
Briggs, then I totally get it.
What if you have a team of
extroverts where actually, the
way they think is thinking out
loud and bouncing ideas off
each other?
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah.
No, this research did test for
that, I mean, it wasn't
culturally bounded and it wasn't
bounded by personality
or preference, so, I mean, the
empirical answer that question
is, that didn't affect it.
But we can go deeper into
looking into this research.
How about, one more?
AUDIENCE: I think following
up on that, I've seen
brainstorming happen where it
was very successful, very
productive, when it follows a
strict process that outlines
exactly what's the goal of
each stage and how to
structure and capture that
input on all of that.
So I'm not sure the research
they referred to was just open
ended brainstorming that people
do whenever they get
together or brainstorming that
is that company like idio does
where that's actually their
value and that's how they sell
themselves.
JAKE BREEDEN: Yeah, well idio in
particular has innovated in
the way, so the short answer
to your question is yes,
structure matters.
And the big enemy is this kind
of general reflexive notion
of, what we need is more people,
more ideas, more
permissiveness about ideas, and
if we just get everybody
sharing stuff, then we'll
be in a good place.
That's the bogeyman that I
want to take down, right?
So if you're talking about an
approach where individuals
have accountability and
responsibility to each come up
with some of their ideas and
then you share, so-called
nominal group technique is one
example of that, then I think,
I'm hopeful, I'm optimistic, I
think we're on the right page.
This particular research was
really focused on which is
better, if I've got eight
people, do I get them in the
room trying to come up with the
answer, or do I separate
these eight people and then
look at what comes out?
And the answer, over and over
again was, you separate them.
If you talk about technique that
says, well what if we can
have the best of both
worlds, OK.
Then I'm hopeful.
And I think that hasn't been
tested in the way that the
other part has been.
So I want to end with
one last thing.
May I?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAKE BREEDEN: Thank you.
Thank you, Sam.
SAM: You're welcome.
JAKE BREEDEN: And the rest of
you, I assume by your silence,
silence is consent, so David
Foster Wallace told a story in
2008 at a graduation speech
at Kenyon College.
Two young fish swimming along,
bobbing in the water, happy as
can be, passed by
and older fish.
And the older fish says to the
younger fish, these two
younger fish, howdy, boys.
And they say back, hello, sir.
And the elders fish says, the
water's nice today, isn't it?
And they said, yeah, yeah.
And then as the old fish passes,
one of the young fish
says to the other young fish,
what the hell is water?
And the point that David Foster
Wallace was making to
the college graduates was that
you're swimming in water so
long, you don't even know
what you're swimming in.
When you're surrounded by it,
it's so hard to see it and
examine it critically
from a distance.
And that's the nature sacred
cows, and I would say it's an
even greater threat for folks
who are experienced
professionals like yourself.
These sacred cows like, what
we need is more creativity
higher standards, more
collaboration.
When you're swimming in these
things so long, so often, so
deeply, it's hard to recognize
when they may be backfiring.
So my advice is to just look at
your world with a healthy,
but a critical distance.
Thank you very much
for your time.
[APPLAUSE]